it is the last week to give to our great
toy Drive Rocky stopped by Tobin Kia of
Tobin Auto Group the sponsors of this
segment to see how the toys are piling
up under chops Christmas tree
the great toy drive is underway going
through the 16th of December chop let's
first and foremost talk about your team
because every dealership I've been in
the Christmas trees and the decorations
have been amazing the teams put it
together wanted to look nice for TV you
know I mean Rockies Las Vegas now is not
a regular TV show we want to be out here
looking right exactly exactly now what
does a chopped Christmas look like it
has a lot of gifts a lot of toys a lot
of unwrapped toys coming from the folks
dropping them off right here the Tobin
locations under the tree in the boxes
that's what it looks like perfect now
explain what kind of toys we're looking
for when you're when the community can
come down and donate we want toys for
younger girls younger boys uh uh you
know uh teenagers pre-teens we do like
gift cards we want for the teens because
that way they can pick the stuff that
they like and so we just want any type
of unwrap toy you can drop off at any
total location and then you know we're
filling up Vans for the kiddos because
we want no kids to wake up at the shade
tree without toys absolutely in the
shade tree this is benefiting the shade
tree they help women and children in
crisis so thank you for what you're
doing for the shade tree thank you guys
for donating to them now let's talk
about Kia you know we are at the Kia the
Tobin Kia dealership what kind of cars
are you giving us so we have the best
cars so one beautiful thing about kids
the most reliable car on the market as
far as JD Power these cars don't break
because I love selling kids because I
sell it and then I don't hear anything
back from that they just they just they
just disappear in their happiness and
then Bliss and so it's just a beautiful
car we have some unbelievable Styles I
know when you're in the streets you see
the Kia Telluride and all these really
cool designs and we're blessed to sell
them with the number one volume dealer
we really want to thank our team over
here for keeping us president's Club
it's the highest award you can win at
Kia and and our team for selling all
these cars and our great customers that
come back and uh visit Tobin Kia the
number one store there you go Chuck
thank you Tobin is the gift that keeps
on giving to this community so thank you
for all you're doing this the great toy
drive going till December 8th 9th 16th
excuse me benefiting the shade tree and
I will send it back to you
all right thank you Rocky the eight news
now great toy drive is in full swing
we're collecting toys and gift cards to
benefit the shade tree you can drop
donations off at any Tobin dealership
around the valley until Friday December
16th so